it's important to remember that behind
the magic of Asgard are lots and lots of
hard-working people and sometimes those
hard-working people goof up or act a
little silly it's with great pleasure
that we present some of the most
hilarious Thor bloopers this side of the
Bifrost the whole thing's a mess taka
the romantic payoff between Leeds is one
of the most anticipated parts of any
film franchise actors and directors go
to great lengths to shoot and perform
the most gratifying scene possible Thor
and Jane keep coming up against all
kinds of obstacles to their love so
whenever they're able to express their
affection for each other it's a brief
respite in the midst of world altering
chaos but it's got to be awkward to kiss
your coworkers sometimes right
especially when you've got your
trademark long blonde Thor locks blowing
into her mouth kinda makes you wonder if
that's part of the reason for Thor
keeping a shortcut later on in the
timeline of the MCU this funny little
snippet from The Dark Worlds gag reel
adds some levity to a somewhat fraught
and difficult relationship and it's nice
to see that even in the midst of
something so intense
Chris Hemsworth and Natalie Portman can
appreciate a little silliness
it seems Edna mode from The Incredibles
was right when she insisted that
superheroes shouldn't wear capes nothing
but Thor is known for his so he would be
remiss to go without still it seems to
have caused a great deal of trouble for
Hemsworth who was shown in several
bloopers batting the great swath of
crimson fabric out of his face you would
think that a weather god who frequently
summons down great winds might consider
ditching the cape in the flowing hair
but he has an image to uphold the
problem that any fashion-forward hero
faces is knowing that looking really
cool often comes at the expense of being
comfortable but it wouldn't do to be a
God who wears a windbreaker and tennis
shoes no one would take him seriously
this very relatable problem humanizes
one of the most powerful beings in the
universe in Norse mythology the great
god Odin has two Raven companions huggin
and muninn these elegant and intelligent
Birds serve as Odin's all-seeing eyes
bringing him the news from Midgard or
earth huggin and muninn don't have a
huge role in the MCU
but it's a nice little nod to Thor's
Norse origins to include them in a scene
where Thor has a heart-to-heart with his
father Odin of course the Ravens on set
are just normal birds even if they are
more intelligent than your average city
pigeon trained animals aren't always
easy to work with and Ravens in
particular are known to be pretty
independent minded creatures instead of
coming off as mystical and mysterious
these bloopers reveal the birds to be
stubborn and a little hard to work with
typical avian divas
luckily they seem to have gotten the
scene down eventually further enveloping
the viewer in the magic of Asgard but
one has to wonder if the real huginn and
muninn ever gave the all-father a hard
time in the old myths Thor and his
brother Loki have a really complicated
relationship which may have something to
do with the fact that Loki is a
trickster God who is never really able
to stick to one side of a fight in Thor
the dark world audiences are given a lot
of screen time with the two brothers as
they've worked together to thwart the
Dark Elves
like any sibling pair the two squabble
incessantly even though it's obvious
that they care about each other and then
this happens not here you get I'm
pressing it I'm pressing pressing yes I
am yeah yeah that's Chris Hemsworth and
Tom Hiddleston Thor and Loki breaking
into uncontrollable giggles it certainly
adds depth to the brotherly love between
their characters a brotherly love that
we can't help but hope extends to the
actors off screen friendship as well in
Thor Ragnarok Thor and Loki are
introduced to the sister they never knew
they had the terrifying in all-powerful
hella goddess of death she takes her job
very seriously
sewing destruction and misery wherever
she goes it is a great blow then to see
the equally stunning Cate Blanchet
stumbled backwards while unleashing some
of that awesome power breaking the
illusion of Hellas deadly poise
[Music]
it's humbling to realize that even
Blanchette one of the most talented and
elegant women in Hollywood also loses
her balance in front of lots and lots of
onlookers when she's trying so hard just
to do her job
watching her running around in a motion
capture suit is also a bit disorienting
when we recall how grandiose hellas
appearances but a deaf goddess has to do
what a death goddess has to do it's
important not to take yourself in your
job too seriously and it seems that no
group knows this better than the cast
and crew of Thor Ragnarok starting with
the eminently witty Jeff Goldblum gag
reel viewers are graced with several
shots of the actors performing fun
little dances presumably breaking up
some of the hurry-up-and-wait monotony
of a typical day on a movie set the
whole thing really makes you want to
join in on the fun of filmmaking and
makes you anticipate watching these
goofy actors and subsequent installments
within the Marvel Cinematic Universe
well half of them at least sorry we
couldn't resist check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]